on à l'avs on a on a l'image et n'aura
elle est en super bowl est comment ça va
super bowl est alors écoutez vous ne
vous mens avait fait faire des trucs
mais alors ça comment vous dire je suis
dans une angoisse
non elle est où la mangeuse de bullet
hell et enfin la baballe cliffs à
l'heure alors toi et tranquille à la
bianchi charles
vous avez vu deux chars y est vous savez
vous revenez du sauna non mais on m'a
dit de me protéger parce que je vais
recevoir les boulettes peut-être dans la
tronche donc à d'accord oui
effectivement c'est fait rien ça vous
êtes plutôt tranquille bah ça va en fait
j'ai un peu le vertige mais je me tiens
donc sans en sort elle est magnifique à
l'audimat sur le pont flottant mon
chapeau le vertige sous le balcon sabra
kouao c'est pas évident tous les jours
subissent y aura un bras bravo beinheim
et enora vous allez devoir traverser le
pont et lancer des boules est à belaili
l'accord elle les attrapera avec une
partie de son corps elle sait faire vous
inquiétez pas les boulettes on a
rattrapé toute sa vie boulette opa
boulette
est-ce qu'elle va réussir à donner
toutes les poules est à valérie bénaïm
on a donc deux personnes sur twitter
voilà qu'on a choisi qui sont avec nous
en ligne à loket à l'appareil
merci allez on va tout de suite
démarrer et enora et on aura les deux
personnes valides pendant la séquence et
nora est ce que vous êtes prêts si les
gens qui tremble c'est vrai ben moi
aussi j'veux pas pourquoi il a dit ça
vibre et l'oci et nora vous y allez
quand vous le sortez le rat d'accord
alors à temps parce que déjà faut que je
me mette là c'est ça certains sports
évidemment fait il aura fait tout ce
chemin est ce que enora et nora est ce
que ça va non non doucement chéri
doucement schering plough est inquiète à
qui ça au [ __ ] je vois en bas c'est
mon nom me regarde pas regarde pas
regarde pas et n'aura je suis très
inquiet est ce que vous voulez qu'on
adule tu es sérieux tu connais sa belle
relance on y va on attend pas
c'est vrai que je suis vraiment angoissé
moi je sais pas pour vous quelle fille
son adossement fait doucement et non
enora je voulais qu'on prenne les appels
au fait bien ce que vous voulez mon avis
enora elles elles sont les boulettes en
tout cas
alors là on a quelqu'un en ligne qui est
un appareil à merci ça marche bien les
appels à ça c'est un truc qu'il faudra
refaire c'est bien une hausse et bien
c'est bien c'est bien alors allo allo
c'est super chéri oublier les appels
oublier speitel avec ça enora ohlala
olala lots et laura savoir te tape taupe
à pennautier bordel tu te calmes
franchement attendu six mois tu te
calmes calment j'ai très très peur
ah mais moi je me sens pas bien je me
sens pas bien je me sens pas bien
enfin c'est loin les poules est une
avant garde rapprochée les profanateurs
lâches au top ch au top là j'ai
l'impression je suis hyper au top
attendez doha et tout doucement tanger
petite pause fait tous prêtres qu'il
faut c'est le rap est une pause mais
tais-toi série es là
mais moi j'essaie de l'aga soutenir et
faire ta gueule oh la la
olalala je sais pas comment il fait bien
je ne sais pas quand mais celle arrêtée
deux tasses et là c'est la plus grande
aventurière oui le de l'équipe rocher
400 fou à la raison mais beau nom mais
si je sais que je ne peux pas regarder
vos boulettes
elle arrive au bout mais à l'arrivée on
voulait être à l'orgue à l'autre qui
rend les lots attention ma chérie tous
mangé et leurs agents qui 30 c horrifié
tu seras pas trop mais c'est me retape
staff et tous m'ont fait danser chez toi
là puisqu'elle fait trois ans personne
n'aurait pu le faire ici je pense à ton
temps chercher quoi que ses pulls s ii
voulait être à temps glisse glisse
doucement je prends toi de la sotrac
dalet a mené les abbey dawn l'egypte je
les avais 90 us à infos que j'ai tant
elle voulait jamais et n'aura de les
jeter les amener mon ca elles sont
coincées est pas parvenu c'est parfait
palou ses mots sa bonne étoile et ça
suffit elle en a assez
à l'est et dans un cas les filles
continuent à avancer et partez partez
marcelo a même chassé chérie ça y est tu
y étais je ne crois pas que quelqu'un
qui tous les problèmes y est ça va ça va
ces bons frérot on y est
non
mais non mais non
messi
et enora la patronne les chéris ashton
hashtag la patronne du tout cela et
penser la science tout si fou ce qu'elle
a fait laura hameaux sionneau je suis je
suis en haut je sais pas pour vous celui
dont on vit des choses incroyables ce
soir